the msnbc un-american activities
committee
is in session and the aforementioned
tucker is in the dock
nicole wallace convened the usual msnbc
panel of deep state propagandists
first up was frank phil uzi the former
assistant director of counter
intelligence
at the fbi not to be confused with peter
strzok the former deputy assistant
director of counterintelligence at the
fbi so
he needs a longer business card mr phil
you see
as a crack counterintelligence g-man
isn't buying
tucker's cockamamie story i
am not convinced at all that this
whistleblower actually
exists in other words what better way
for tucker carlson to cover his rear end
because he's called a russian
intelligence officer or intermediary
for the kremlin he gets worried about it
he decides i'm going to go on the
offensive
i'm going to announce that the nsa is
listening to me and have them try and
deny it
and so i think it's good cover but as
you said there's something much
larger going on here it is another page
in the playbook
of folks like tucker carlson and folks
in the gop
who simply want to continue to erode the
public's trust
in their institutions oh my
i like the way he painted all those
wiley coyote cacti behind him so we
wouldn't know he's in the yukon
that's your counterintelligence deep
cover right there so as this guy phil
uses he sees it the main problem
with chaka revealing that the national
security agency is reading his emails
is that it might erode the public's
faith that the name
of the national security agency suggests
it has
something to do with national security
if ever there were an institution in
which the public's trust
should be eroded it's these guys but
don't even entertain that thought
because that'll make you
just as anti-american as tucker here's
the second member
of msnbc's deep state propagandist panel
andrew weissman if that name rings a
vague bell he was a member of robert
mueller's
russia-russia-russia investigation and
managed to parlay that
into a book deal and a cnn gig and mr
weissman thinks that
tucker of all people should know that
when you discover that big brother is
reading your emails the appropriate
response
is to fill in a ministry of truth
comment card
and set up an appointment to come in and
see the commissar general
so he can explain to you all the
safeguards that are in place but that if
you're still not totally reassured
he'll ask for a budget increase so he
can put some safeguards on some of the
safeguards
you know what i'm concerned about here
is not that there was incidental
collection
when i am calling a foreigner including
of course if you try and reach out to
vladimir putin you can pretty much uh be
sure that you're
going to be that high risk of being
intercepted he could have said look
there's a first amendment
issue here and i want to make sure that
there are safeguards at the department
of justice
but he didn't take that route he did as
you said
and as frank pointed out he wanted to
use this really for his own purposes
and to so distrust which is so
anti-american
instead of raising a legitimate issue
about safeguards
in the system when you're dealing with
journalists
yes tucker is sowing distrust which is
so anti-american
nothing says i'm a loyal patriotic
american like taking a relaxed
attitude to the national security agency
hoovering
up your texts and emails it was revealed
in the edward snowden leaks back in 2013
that the nsa
collected the communications of over a
billion
people that's a seventh of the world's
population
what do you think it's up to a decade on
a billion and a half
two billion meanwhile one guy just one
guy just the one
chairman she is taking over the planet
but the big
bloated behemoth of a national security
agency is too busy
collecting the emails of gladys
scroggins of 27b strathcona gardens and
the outer hebrides
the nsa has claimed that its
surveillance program
prevented 13 terrorism attacks in the
united states obviously it's failed to
prevent many more than that
but taking their claim at face value
that would mean preventing
one terrorism attack for every 76
million
923 076 people
under collection and in fact there's not
even any evidence for the prevention
of those 13 attacks quote from the days
when nbc's news division wasn't quite so
gung-ho
for surveillance state cheerleading
quote a member of the white house review
panel
on nsa surveillance said he was
absolutely surprised
when he discovered the agency's lack of
evidence that the bulk collection of
telephone call records
had to thwarted any terrorist attacks
it was ha hello what are we doing here
said jeffrey stone a university of
chicago law professor
in an interview with nbc news one
question the white house panel was
seeking to answer was whether it had
actually
stopped any terror attacks that might
have been really big
we found none said stone but presumably
that could all change now that tucker's
emails are in the system
there's a fine line between a secret
intelligence service
and a secret police the former is
difficult business
the ladder is a lot easier and we have
given our guys
powers that incentivize any inclinations
they might have in that direction the
one and only
tucker carlson joins me now
tucker we're a couple of weeks into this
thing how are you feeling about it
well i just i don't watch a lot of
television so i'm always amazed when i
see clips like that
i mean first of all to be lectured on
patriotism by people who think america's
systemically racist is i mean it's
it's beyond belief the fact that andrew
weissman is on
television and apparently paid a corrupt
prosecutor which he is
not ought to be facing charges for what
he did uh during the russia
investigation
instead he's waxing on about what
patriotism is and how if you complain
about the corrupt system then you're
unpatriotic
submit to you know an unjust system uh
or else you're a bad person but at the
very beginning the former the the fbi's
i think
the fbi stooge at the in the first clip
said something that really does reveal a
lot he said well really this is
cover because carlson was emailing with
people or talking to people he shouldn't
be talking to and he was worried about
that
and you think who thinks like that i'm
an american i can talk to anybody i want
i can have any opinion i want i'm not
embarrassed about my opinions i'm not
embarrassed about who i talk to why
would i be
again if you think i'm committing a
crime charge me with one who even think
i mean
that's a kind of totalitarian way to
think and i
and i hope it hasn't infected the
country just to recap as an american
citizen you have the right to talk to
anyone you want to
about anything you want to and reach any
conclusion you want to
those are the rules that's absolutely
true if you recall
major hassan way back at the time of the
fall hood attack
he was being monitored by three
different
intelligence agencies because it's money
uh
no object uh in in our quote
intelligence community
and he said uh he it was determined by
all three agencies that when he was
speaking with the terrorist guy
or lackey in yemen he was in contact
with that guy that that didn't matter
because that was consistent with his
research interests
why don't you get the pass that major
hassan got
by those three cockamamie useless
agencies
a decade ago because they weren't trying
to control and silence
hassan and that's that's really the
story here it's not simply that my
emails were collected
by our intel bureaucracies but that my
name was unmasked and
legally they would have had someone
would have had to request that and that
would have been
signed off on by the head of by the
director of the nsa
um and then that information was leaked
to news agencies in an effort to
discredit me i'm not speculating about
this and just
just to say once again this is not the
kind of
point that you would make lightly i have
zero interest in talking about myself or
who i email or making the story about me
there's no kind of no upside in it for
me obviously but it happened
it's an outrage and if it continues to
happen to others and we know that it is
then democracy really does die it's
worth finding out
how they did this what the justification
for it was
and it's worth punishing the people who
did it because if they continue to do it
again
you can't have a functioning democracy
well i'd be interested to know whether
they've actually done this to
other people who then found out about it
and decided not to do what you did i
mean
those two fbi stooges department of
justice stooges are complaining that you
had the
cheek the nerve the less major stay
to go public with it um and so i take it
from that that they've done this to
other guys who decided just to go all
quiet
and uh start doing instead of talking
about current affairs decide to start
doing ballet reviews or something well
well we know for certain that they have
and it just so happens that
you know i don't have anything to hide
and so i'm not embarrassed to say hey
back off you're not it's illegal what
you're doing don't do it
but i know plenty of people who are too
afraid
to criticize them including sitting
members of congress are supposed to be
overseeing them
so what does that tell you if you have
an intelligence agency with as you
pointed out
massive funding that operates
independently of political control of
political leadership then that
undermines the very idea of democracy
they're not their own country they're
bureaucrats who work for us
they're outraged when you ask them
questions they refuse to answer them
they act
like you know where do you get off
questioning me really
i mean i just think if we allow that
attitude to persist
then all is lost no the the proper
posture is
hey federal bureaucrat you work for me
i pay your salary answer the question
now or you're fired
like why wouldn't that be absolutely i
would love to
i would love to hear a republican uh
candidate a republican office holder
actually say other than rand paul and
one or two others say
these guys are out of control they do
nothing for national security
uh it's totally misnamed uh and they're
just using it now systemically to
backdoor their way
into the lives of american citizens they
want to take down somehow
well that is exactly right and of course
none do
and over in the senate i mean that the
top republican in the senate mitch
mcconnell of kentucky
ask anybody who works in the united
states senate they'll tell you you know
green light whatever they want i mean
they endorse this stuff i i think
republicans have been very slow to
understand that what these agencies are
doing and i'd include the fbi in this as
well which is
absolutely a huge intel gathering
operation there's not just a law
enforcement agency
what they're doing is totally corrosive
of our system if you're worried about
our democracy
and i think we should be this is
something to fix
right now i wish the last administration
had fixed it they were afraid too
that tells you how powerful these people
are i'm not it's not look i'm not a
crazy person overstating the case
i spent 35 years in washington i know
exactly how it works and so do these
morons on tv too
they know they know how it works and
they're lying
one of the reasons why we're losing the
war on terror tucker actually is because
we don't fight enough of it in public
uh with civilizational confidence
but we're doing it all with a secret
surveillance state
uh where we're now effectively bringing
the strategy that's failed in
afghanistan
onto the home front that's what we're
doing tucker
you know we would get a lot farther if
we had
values that we could espouse in public
be proud of i mean
you can't be a powerful country if you
don't
believe in the ideas that undergird your
society and that's i guess another irony
being lectured about patriotism
by people who really don't believe in
our founding documents and the basic
principles of america
oh it's head spinning
there speaks truth from the
anti-american folks we'll see in 40
minutes uh or so
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else